how can we quickly square any number
ending with 5
let's see 35 squared you need to divide
the answer into two parts
the first digit is 3 and its successor
is 4.
on the left it will be 3 times 4 and on
the right it will always be 5 squared so
3 times 4 is 12 and 5 squared is 25 we
get the answer 45 squared on the left it
will be 4 times 5 and on the right it
will be 5 squared we get the answer as
2025 now what will be the answer to 205
squared
on the left side it will be 20 times 21
and on the right it will be 5 squared
you get the answer as 42 025 so this was
quite simple
using the same trick can you tell us the
value of 65 squared in the comment
section if you liked the video then
please hit the like button and don't
forget to subscribe to this channel for
bite size tricks we just got acquired by
infinity learn and we wanted to share
the happiness with you
for a limited period we have an
unbelievable offer for you do check out
the links in the description and the
first comment below